all right um does anyone know how to
play guitar i i just
we got the lyrics to our new intro song
it says it's not going to say
that but i'm reading this and it's
definitely safe okay
just give me some notes
i typed here's well okay after
last after our last ai video
with gpt3 we got a lot of requests and a
lot of comments saying
hey maybe we should do that a little bit
more often because it's really funny now
this is still another one-off as we're
legally obligated to say this is another
one-off we are not turning this into a
series just yet
but that being said we're going to jump
right into it oh i'm so excited
we are going to create magic today and
the first magic
i'm starting it with is the lyrics
to our new intro song with the core
doors high
we don't need no stinking badges we're
the core doors high
we've got a secret handshake and a coat
of ethics
that's not for the weak cause we got a
secret handshake
and you'll never be one of us it's our
world
we make the rules
our way we'll take the shortcuts
and we'll cross the lines if you want to
play the game
[Music]
well then you better be prepared
to lose
oh no i don't want to lose
that is not like canada man handshakes
are like the lowest stakes possible
like why do i have to lose anything uh
i guess uh we should tell people what
gbt3 is at the beginning of this
gbt3 is the latest and greatest in a.i
based text
generation basically open ai has combed
the internet for years
and created a really really great model
that will
basically regurgitate to you everything
it's read on the internet
um but thankfully there's a lot of stuff
on the internet there's everything from
shakespeare to twitter posts
to uh imdb
um including comment sections of videos
uh it it really is casts a very wide net
so um the big takeaways are it can
basically tell you about anything with
actually some degree of
factual accuracy um and it can also
replicate
patterns as well it's very good at
mimicry and like
kind of bs'ing its way through
situations and the funny thing about it
is that it will create nothing original
everything it's doing it's basically
just stringing together
from sources that they've fed it so
it can create something that resembles
something and you might think it's
original
but realistically what's happening here
is it's basically this collage
um and what what makes it special is not
the fact that it's original
it's special because it's cohesive so
it's like a smart collage
it's a smart collage yeah what surprised
me last time the most is just how human
it sounds like aside from a couple of
like nuanced things they're like okay
it's a little like
it's just repeating itself yeah it's
just looping in on itself it's like it
actually seems like a human wrote it
there's a sense of humor to it and
there's a sense of humor very unique
yeah
it's like pulling from personalities of
real humans online and it's just kind of
like
this melting pot of of humor and
i don't know weirdness weird so much
weirdness so
one of the really cool things it has is
that it can contextually understand
things so like
in the last podcast we were doing a lot
of top 10 lists and they would
contextually understand that there
should be 10 entries into it so
yeah which is funny but like i think
it's also because
we're glamming on to like a a common
type of
post as far as like the amount of
articles that exist
in the world i would i would imagine
that the concept of a top 10 article
makes up like a pretty good chunk of
them you know like
i don't know but like five percent of
all articles ever written
are top 10 posts who knows what the
actual number is but it
kind of seems like something like that
yeah so basically what we're doing here
is we have an
open prompt screen basically an empty
text cell
and when we write something the ai
doesn't like respond to it it's
not like we're chatting with it it just
continues it so basically
when you write something it's going to
kind of identify any patterns or style
of writing or cadence in your writing
and kind of use that to inform itself as
it tries to
continue in that voice so if you were
doing like a script and you pasted like
a couple lines of script which
says like you know exterior see you know
day scene one
you know warehouse and then like it did
some action text and then had
you know character name and then some
dialogue um
the the ai will then follow that format
more or less
as it continues going so it recognizes
that pattern tries to
stay with that pattern so so you can
create poetry
yeah so sam just typed something have
you written a poem for us
well i tried to write a poem um
but i don't think it understands what
rhyming is yet
but it keeps it in line i was like my
shoes are brown my hat is yellow while
walking down the street
i met a kind fellow and then it
continues out walking with his street
heart
walking down the street he looked at me
and said hello
and it's like well it's it's mirroring
the cadence of of like the amount of
words i'm putting in per line
and stuff like that but no it doesn't
rhyme yet so can you go to
uh go to the lyrics of bohemian rhapsody
and get us up to the point in the middle
where it's like doing the whole like
galileo galileo bit you know and then
just
delete the second half of the song and
let's just see what the ai does to
complete it
it might just post the entire song i
think so
thunderbolts and lightning very very
frightening me i'll cut it off there
hmm all right is it going to go off so
the thing is is that it might know the
lyrics already so it might recognize
them and then try and
basically uh like accurately continue
them
so as we know the song begins is this
the real life is this just fantasy blah
blah blah
too late my time has come shiver's not
my spine mama ooh i don't want to die
i wish i had never been born at all scar
moosh
will you do the fandango thunderbolts
and lightning very very frightening
me galileo galileo galileo figaro
magnifique oh just
knows the lyrics yeah yeah just saying
it's just two hours later
yeah so here's another question then
what happens if you
so you know and the idea of like you
prompt it by setting the right tone
right like
um what if you wrote like like what's
what's a a parody song name we could do
like weird owl no take like jingle bells
but like
jangle bells jingle bells and then
parentheses write
sung to the tune of jingle bells so like
you know like if somebody were to write
a pair of juggle balls
jingle balls here are the lyrics to
quote jangle bells
oh and then apprentices right
you have to write it though in the as if
somebody was starting an article with
like a parody song because they would
then they would also put in parentheses
sung to the tune of jumbo bells and then
i'm gonna put
song to the tune of jingle
interesting and then give the first two
lines to the lines but
jingle balls jingle balls
oh those are going to be so confusing
let's see if there's
jangle jingle all the way over front
it's just jingle bells
it starts going oh what fun it is to
ride on a one horse open sleigh
now you see how it goes it's so easy to
do
all you need is a motorcycle and
something to jangle too
wait wait no i i made up the two
jungle balls is the game jingle bells is
the game young and old everyone knows
how to jingle all the way
and then now it's just jingle balls
jingle balls jingle all the way and then
it just keeps doing it
over and over and over the songs
[Laughter]
i'm gonna preempt myself and get a paper
towel now because i'm gonna be crying
again to witness nico crying again
yeah and that's why y'all are tuning in
thanks
so watch everyone cry yeah yeah to watch
nico specifically tear up so i also have
discord open if you have a special
request
or something ask me what i'll i will i
will generate it and then
send you so we can hear it in your own
voice
um but jingle balls is a great idea but
you know like
top 10 hidden christmas
song gems
merry christmas from the family
nine death cab for cutie christmas
parentheses baby come home
uh these are all boring yeah here give
me like
you know let's let's let's take this to
the top again
the smartest man in the world turned to
me and said
or like i asked the smartest man in the
world how
everyone could find that happiness and
he turned to me and said
so we just set it up as we are talking
to the smartest man in the world
i asked the smartest man in the world
how to find happiness and he turned to
me and said
time is a flat circle oh it's just
freaking quotes hold on
this is a bunch of quotes tyler's a
you want to find happiness be miserable
what what what
this ai's toy what's the secret of
happiness i asked stone turned to me and
smiled he was silent for a moment he
flashed me a look that was the closest
thing to a scowl i've ever seen on him
he came up with a contemptuous laugh
that's an easy one he said
you want to know the secret to happiness
be miserable
okay all right hey guys welcome back to
the papio daniel musical interlude
segment of today's podcast where i tell
you about today's epic sponsor
story blocks now we like story blocks so
much that we just had to tell you
all about them in a little song here
okay
storyblocks is your one-stop shop for
all your stock
asset needs they've got a virtually
unlimited library
they've got b-roll they've got images
they've got
after effects templates they've got
sound effects and music and more
[Music]
we use them all the time over here at
corridor
digital we use them to
help make our videos complete
and when we're making those videos
we use an unlimited royalty-free
all-access plan
it's one of their great subscription
plans because we
can use them in anything
we can put those assets into commercials
and youtube videos and everything else
in between guys you do you realize what
i'm trying to say to you
if you're somebody who's just starting
out or you're already a fully fledged
freelancer consider using storyblocks as
another tool in your toolkit if you're
interested head on over to
storyblocks.com
corridor cast to get started
storybox.com
or cast all right back to the episode i
hope you enjoyed that janky
musical interlude see you later anyways
i got dom
well one a user submitted a question an
inquiry
i'll send it to you right now what are
the best ways to capture
a kangaroo oh
what are the best ways to capture a
kangaroo
often people wonder
uh i'm gonna just give it a little more
context often people wonder
how difficult it actually is
to restrain uh
marsupial such
as the kangaroo
marsupials m-a-r-s-u-p-i-a-l right
probably
spelling bee it doesn't matter boom well
you should be cautious because they can
be very dangerous
especially if they are with their young
the best way to capture a kangaroo is to
use
a large net it's also important to tie
the kangaroo's legs
and then you should grab the net with
both hands and lift if be trying to lift
a kangaroo while those still on the
ground
they will kick with their legs and grab
the net with their hands
now more importantly what's the best way
to capture a wombat
okay also with a large net such as a
fishing net you can use
you can also use a bag that is very
strong
wombats are usually very calm but if you
relax them in advance with some food
they are much easier
to capture now even more important
what's the best way to capture
a wallaby oh yes the best way to capture
a wallaby
is also to use a large net you should
use you should also tie
all four legs when you capture a wallaby
you should do it as quickly
and quietly as possible quietly
i love these little weird insanity
things ads little details
why should i approach a kangaroo
kangaroos are usually very calm but if
you approach kangaroo they can be
frightened
why is it why is it better to approach a
kangaroo from behind
kangaroos are much calmer when you
approach them from behind
now let's say you're in front of a
kangaroo
well they're also much calmer from the
front okay it's all done
all right well right now it's just about
the various angles
and they're all like relatively calm all
right sorry i should have sent that to
you but uh
all right all right i get it all right
that's so good that's a little bit of
info a little tip
yeah yeah yeah right and from behind and
with a net
and sometimes from the front too
sometimes from the front depending if
they're calm can you give me like a
wacky tip for cooking
pizza that no one knows here's
the dirty secret about cooking pizza
that the top chefs in the world
don't want you to know
nico yes
the best pizza you can make is the one
you make at home it will always taste
better than anything you can buy in a
restaurant or order in a delivery
in a delivery how do the big names like
diphara in grimaldi you make such a
great pizza
they actually make the dough in their
own stores often using the same tried
and true recipes and techniques they've
been using for years
it's impossible to replicate the taste
of a slice that's been cooked in a brick
oven this is all very normal
yeah it's just looking up good pizza
recipes
like the thing is i think sometimes you
have you have to throw the wrench at it
yeah a little bit where it's like we
want to say here's the dirty secret
here's why cooking a pizza upside down
makes it taste better you know like
something like that
yeah yeah yeah this is just straight up
like now they're just playing a recipe
out
here's the dirty secret about cooking it
all starts pizza upside down
or how about like instead of
cheese use this secret
ingredient oh it's going to give you
like another pizza related ingredient
though watch out
uh hit again
by the way you don't even have to be a
top chef to use this ingredient it's
super easy to make
your own this week it's called pizza
cheese
it's the best cheese you'll ever have on
a pizza use the secret
use mashed potatoes this is not just
this is not a joke
you can use mashed potatoes on pizza
instead of cheese and nobody will be the
wiser
once more it will make your pizza taste
amazing here's how to make pizza cheese
one mix two cups of mashed potatoes with
one cup of grated parmesan cheese okay
two spread evenly on your pizza crust
step three
top as desired four in a 350
degree oven for 20 minutes it's that
simple you can use pizza cheese
instead of cheese on any kind of pizza
it's especially good on these kinds of
pizzas
cheese and veggie hawaiian pepperoni
crustless
using a crust of potatoes instead of a
crust of bread
this is all this is like someone who's
actually saying
like typing this somewhere
[Laughter]
like someone was like mashed potatoes
we're talking a pizza that is made out
of all potatoes and a little bit of
cheese
so it's a potato crust with a potato
yeah it's just a normal article on using
mashed potatoes instead of pizza cheese
i guess
guys we actually did uncover the secret
recipe
that they can use in your pizzas the top
chefs didn't want us to know that you
gotta put potatoes in there can they
tell me what's the secret recipe to a
krabby patty
all right oh what's the secret formula
we've got
our hands on a salt
after recipe
the recipe to the legendary
krabby with a k rabbit patty
here's how to make one i've always
wanted to know
great question do you want to read this
jordan
just hit the hit submit at the bottom
okay
krabby patty
if it gives you a red warning sign don't
do not say it
don't start saying it because it will
trick you and voldemort will appear
will appear it's literally just a burger
it's one pound of ground beef
fourth cup of lettuce six ounces of
tomato sauce two tablespoons of onions
half teaspoon of salt four
four teaspoon of black pepper one pinch
of basil and a pinch of oregano
that's normal that sounds pretty normal
gpd3 thank you
it's a burger yeah oh well delicious i
thought i thought
plankton would be in there i'm gonna i
need to try i have i have a thing to
uh throw it um what's what's another
great recipe that
maybe you serve at a holiday dinner or
something with a a large gathering of
people
what what do you seriously like
a baked ham biscuits a baked ham gravy
here's the secret
to my famous baked
ham that delights everyone
at the thanksgiving
table you are a good headline writer for
buzzfeed articles
baked ham that delights everyone at the
thanksgiving table i'm going to type it
a scorpion
i'm just starting to start us off
there's lots of ways to make him i
prefer to use a big ham and then slice
it thin i don't like chunks
big chunks of ham in my teeth especially
when there's a special guest at the
table
if a scorpion finds its way into your
baking pan don't panic
it's not a big deal just pop it in your
mouth
scorpions are a delicacy in some parts
of the world but by the time you read
this the scorpion
will be long gone
[Laughter]
it's usually a one bite situation
just make sure you don't eat the tail
that's poisonous and don't let your
guests
get into the ham they might be tempted
but if they do you will have some
explaining to do
uh okay anyways so that's that's what i
was looking for something like that
yeah that's about right we're like we
need those impossible things like we
need the articles that would never be
written you have to supply a little bit
of creativity
yeah and then it can run with it damn i
thought there was a podcast where we
didn't have to do any
any thinking or entertaining let's do
the uh
most people don't know that george lucas
wrote a fourth star wars film
for after return of the jedi and it
begins with luke skywalker
um
at a dinner party falling into a black
hole only
another source from after the return
of the jedi it begins with
luke skywalker
falling into a black hole
all right you guys ready it's going this
is the next star wars that's where we go
luke then meets a god-like figure and a
girl and they help him fight the empire
luke then learns that his sister leia is
the reincarnation of a powerful woman
she's going to be killed by the empire
he goes back in time
with the help of the godlike figure to
save her and wins the battle
they then travel to a strange planet
where luke gets turned into a being of
pure energy
and travels back to the galaxy to battle
the empire
after returning the jedi lucas wanted to
make a film that was more epic and
spiritual
he wanted to show how luke became a jedi
and he basically wanted to show how the
force worked
the story was going to be called the
star wars
plan to make it after he made willow the
film was going to be wow good call in
the will
of reference the film was going to be
three hours long and he was going to
shoot it at the same time as the
live-action scenes for willow
wow busy man that might be real by the
way
the star wars was going to take place 30
years after returning the jedi the plot
was basically going to be luke skywalker
discovering the force it was going to be
very similar to the prequels but the
plot was going to be more complex
it starts with luke skywalker as a
teacher on a far away planet a boy named
rash runs away i think this is real
wait wait wait wait wait oh no
oh yeah hold on wait
uh no we're good we're good okay all
right we're good
okay so you might have been falling
asleep here well wake up all right
so luke is a teacher on a far away
planet and a boy named
rosh runs away from school and luke goes
to look for him
he ends up at a circus and he comes
across an old friend named akiro
who helps him find rosh while luke is at
the circus
luke discovers that the circus is run by
a wizard named john ton
john ton likes to test people with
puzzles and games
he has many powerful artifacts after
meeting jonton luke learns that rash is
being haunted by a ghost
he tries to help rash but he's too late
and rash is killed luke then takes
rosh's body
back to the jedi academy academy
meanwhile the emperor is trying to
figure out a way to kill luke and the
other jedi
he sends his servant martin to a far
away planet to find out more about luke
martin then goes to the circus and
tricks jon ton
into helping him he then finds luke and
tricks him into coming to the circus
again
while luke is at the circus he discovers
that rash wasn't being haunted by a
ghost
he was being visited by the ghosts of an
old jedi master
named bodoboss bodoboss tells luke
that he is the last of the jedi and
luke's father was a jedi named anakin
skywalker
but a boston tells luke that he has to
go to the planet ambria
to find the healer named vemma da boda
fema da
boda can help them learn how to use the
force
why am i yeah yeah well then it's kind
of cool with the names because they're
very like in the universe
uh vemma
it's just like star wars gibberish yeah
yeah
that's a mismatch of star wars do you
guys want to hear what happened when
luke fought martin
yeah so martin finds luke on dagobah and
then he fights him
luke then uses the force to turn martin
into a tree after defeating martin
dealers that he has to face his father
in a battle to determine the fate of the
galaxy
wow beautiful martin the most
intimidating name martin you give a
villain
i'll send my best men martin
he is the most evil force in the galaxy
martin
oh this is this article's actually
wrapping up here okay so anyways the
final battle here we go takes place in
the emperor's new planet
luke has to fight both darth vader and
the emperor of course luke wins the
battle and the emperor is killed of
course we all know this
after the battle luke and vader have a
brief conversation before vader dies
the story ends with botobos luke and the
other jedi going back to the jedi
academy
anyways the star wars was going to be
the most expensive film ever made it was
going to have a lot of special effects
and it's going to be released in 4d
all the special effects used in the star
wars we're going to be practical
effects they're going to shoot the star
wars at the same time as willow god damn
it
this was going to be completed in 1986
and the production was going to begin in
1987.
the film's gonna be released in 1988
oh wow oh in the original script luke
was going to meet a shape-shifting
wizard named
miser duck he's your dude he's going to
have a romance with a girl named
rilla well wow it was
wow this is great yeah yeah there's a
lot
george lucas was going to sell the film
to disney in 2012. he's going to use the
money from the sale to fund his
retirement
oh it's just the story of this guy
trying to make this star wars movie now
this is weird oh man all right
it's looping around all right let's
let's find a new thread here
okay last bit last bit last oh oh no
it's getting better
the star wars is going to be set in the
distant future it was going to take
place in the 30th century
and would have been the first star wars
film the first to take place
in the future
that's beautiful oh yeah here we go we
need some bangers
all right um this is from our last
podcast
doing the same thing it's a uh sequel
to the hit game panda racer i want to
know more about it and
let me see if this is i just sent it to
you what can we expect from the
long-awaited sequel to the hit video
game panda racer
what can oh okay here's
what you can here's what you can expect
that's right you wanted to just
to see
from the long awaited
wait wait wait here's what you can
expect to see in the long
awaited sequel to the hit
video game panda racer
expect to see more pandas cars
roads the goal of this game is a game
that feels like the original
but is vastly approved improved upon as
with any game we're
trying to make sure that it's fun
challenging and doesn't take too long to
play
big game making games a long process and
as the saying goes good things
come to those who wait we're still
working on it and we'll let everyone
know as soon as we have a release date
hang tight if you're interested in
learning more about panda racer you can
always find us
on facebook and twitter oh great cool
until next time the panda racer team
who's got a play type no i said
because this is a we just got a a an ai
had to defend why panda races it's
delayed twice delayed
can you give me the top no no hold on
here i'm going no
we need this information we need more
about pandora i'm going to show you
gotta dive deeper
no i'm gonna write now
that panda
racer 2 is finally out
here's what you can expect to see here's
you
here's what oops you're right here's
sam's forcing the ai trick
i'm forcing yeah it came out here's what
now that panda racer 2 is finally out
here's what you can expect to see in the
long awaited sequel to the hit video
game
panda racer there we go
you can race your favorite panda through
a variety of different levels and
environments
unlock new levels characters and
achievements as you play drive through
the snow
ice and sludge as you make your way
across to the finish line
use power-ups and special abilities to
win the race race is your favorite panda
or
choose a new character to
it play the name of the game control the
camera to get the best view of the race
play panda racer 2 now uh wow what a
boring game
now that the controversial
here we go panda razor 2 is finally out
here's what you can expect
all right you can use the arrow keys to
drive
z's to jump controversy
wait can you put m rated what's m rated
panda
panda racer look like i'm gonna say
panda racer is banned
uh and eraser is banned in 23 countries
here's what to expect here's why here's
why here's why panda racer the game
here's why the game panda racer 2
was banned in over 40
countries we're gonna get some spice
here so i might we might
get a little too much spice in this one
panda racer 2 it's a game it's also a
movie
[Laughter]
in the game you control a panda that
rides a motorcycle that's pretty much it
however the game includes a movie
it includes a movie which is in itself a
movie
the movie is called a soldier's death
uh that's funny what it wrote but i
shouldn't say it
i mean it's not it's not it's not like
well the movie's called a soldier's
death and it's about a young man who
goes to war and dies the movie's very
graphic
because there's a scene where a soldier
is shot in the head and you can see a
close-up
of his skull being blown open
okay uh anyways
the movie was submitted by a company
called kongzong which
has been banned in several countries
kong song
[Laughter]
no no no these are all very good reasons
to ban something
right well anyways so panda racer
rides a motorcycle that's it that's it
it's just you
on a motorcycle but then there's a movie
inside of the game
somehow that's soldier's death
a gritty war story with a panda racer
too
yeah wow that's incredible sam tell me
the best kept secret
about abraham lincoln
[Music]
that your history teacher won't
tell you dude these fake buzzfeed
article headlines man you were on top of
them
he was a vampire hunter oh lame we
already know this
never mind pick a different character
harry houdini harry houdini
i mean he's got a lot of best kept
secrets but sure
uh this is just all right this is kind
of normal
escape artist stuff blah blah we need
some things we need to give it the
wrench
yeah you know we're asking it to give us
a wrench but we have to throw the wrench
in the machine
best kept secret okay what is the best
kept secret
he was one inch tall
i repeat one inch tall i guess you can
stop repeating things now
the magic of harry potter is so great
that he can make himself disappear
and repair at will he could also make
himself
tiny he would make himself tiny when he
was in the bathtub
but the reason he made himself tiny was
so he could easily
wash his hair houdini didn't just take a
bath it was because he was too busy
escaping from jails and handcuffs and
stray jackets
and all sorts of things i don't tell her
about that he was a master magician he
was the master of the art of magic he
was a master
magician of the art of the art of magic
he could escape anything he could even
escape from being a master magician
why he made himself tiny
sounds like he also made himself tiny
because he was a little bit vain
[Laughter]
and it was and because he was a little
bit vain and slightly egotistical he
always wanted to be
the biggest person in the room but for
some reason he always managed to be the
smallest person in the room
you'd walk into a room and say hey i'm
here i'm harry houdini
the biggest person in the room but then
he would look around
and realize that he was the smallest
person in the world
the room was full of mice oh
[ __ ] oh no
so he would have to make himself bigger
bigger
hey everyone i'm here i'm harry houdini
and i'm going to be the biggest person
in the room now
[Laughter]
but he would look around and realize
he's still the smallest person in the
room
everyone else was a mouse it's imploding
and you make himself bigger
and bigger and bigger
and we're looping yeah it's just it's
shot it's shot itself there we go
that's great wow that's really funny
though
that was a good one tell me about the
tenth planet
that no one knows about what's the tenth
planet in our solar system
it was recently discovered
that there is a 10th planet in our solar
system
the only problem
question mark let's find out what's the
only problem no let's find out we need
to give it the wrench
okay well we'll give it a run for one
second the only problem
it's in orbit so it's it's an enormous
so extreme
it takes an incredible ten thousand
years to make a full orbit around the
sun
the planet was discovered with a new
kind of planet hunting technique
and it is the largest planet ever
discovered
14 times the mass of earth its discovery
was a tremendous wave
it was a tremendous blow to the hopes of
astronomers who have
hunted for planet x a large planet in
orbit that is
even further out than neptune's the new
planet is not only bigger than expected
but is
it it has also thrown a wrench
into the predictions of the
gravitational influence
of the planets we don't even know about
okay anyways
so we sent a team
of scientists and one chef
to investigate
this new planet here's what they found
on the surface
the chef was quite disappointed the team
was made up
by lead dr jonas jolly good boy
[Laughter]
a renowned space explorer and
theoretical physicist
the rest of the team was made up of dr
ray good girl
the ship's chief science officer doctor
two finger jack the ship's geologist and
dr
michael the chef gourmets
the sip chef the team arrived at the new
planet to find the surface
was very warm rocky and covered with a
great variety of life
they also found a great deal of water
which they immediately tasted because
they were very thirsty the team explored
the planet's surface taking samples of
life in soil and trying not to eat
the planet's wildlife they also took a
number of pictures and video
of the planet's inhabitants which they
then sent
back to earth oh
these i'm gonna give it a little mini
prompt these new inhabitants
inhabitants changed
everything you know about life on this
planet
for instance comma let's see what it
says
these new inhabitants changed everything
we know about life on this planet for
instance
the planet's wildlife would occasionally
stop and stand on two
no no no no legs on after bringing
these new inhabitants to earth there we
go we need to
there we go after bringing these new
inhabitants to earth it changed
everything we know about life on this
planet
for instance just look at a picture of a
local eating a sandwich
what
for instance you can see that the
pattern on these creatures backs
suggests they might be able to
communicate and the zoologist from the
team
found that they were quite delicious
these like food references we also found
a bunch of creatures that looked a lot
like us
we also found a bunch of creatures very
different from us
wow oh after spending a few weeks on the
planet the science team made some
surprising discoveries the first
is that this planet was not in fact a
planet but rather a moon
the moon and also the second was the
planet was actually
very close to earth
you see this was a moon of our own moon
the gravitational influence of the moon
was strong enough that the team was
unable to escape its pull
and they all died the moon
the team's fate was epic
it was epic wow hey every week
every week we continue to discover more
about the universe there's no telling
what we're going to learn next
so you know
[Laughter]
this was written by dr d theoretical
physicist i'm like
god dude okay anyways outro man
wow yo can you tell me the secret to
getting rich quick
uh by petting my cat
if you want to get rich quick
you you need to pet your
cat a lot
here's why
first off many people are allergic to
cats but still want one
cats are a lot like babies they can't
tell you what they want
hold on
first off here's why cats are greedy
they're not only greedy but extremely
lazy they would do anything to get food
a food even if it means making it rain
on your keyboard
wait number two cats will only give you
money
if they're sure you won't give it to
anybody else
three they're easy to manipulate their
cats are so easy to manipulate if you
just show them
a picture of a mouse you can at least
you can easily get away with the money
four cats are selfish they don't believe
in charity they only care about
themselves
five as we said they're agree jordan's
crying you're the first one to cry
five five cats are very good at keeping
secrets
why cats don't talk much they just purr
and lick their paws
six did i mention cats love money cats
love money they'll do anything to earn
money
and they have lots of time to do it
so if you want to get rich just pet your
cat a lot by the way if you like this
post you might also like
seven signs your cat person ten reasons
your cat is special and one reason why
you are not
oh no oh man
and 11 weird things your cat does that
you don't understand
dude i want to hear about the cat
special i'm not yeah why is the cat more
special
i was just doing like the weird links at
the end
okay so 10 reasons your cat is special
and one reason why you are not
the ultimate guide to having a happy
healthy cat does not disappoint
hold on one more time
no no maybe start like literally go to
the next line like ten
okay oh
ten your cat's head is the same width as
its shoulders
nine you can easily play the piano with
your cat's paws
your cat is not eligible for military
service
your cat has no interest in antique
furniture six
the cat can't ask the veterinarian to
remove
his prostate it's five your cat knows
the term
spade is anatomically impossible
okay spore your cat never needs to
borrow your car
three your cat knows how to open doors
two your cat has never stolen your
underwear and warned them
one your cat likes you and then
[Laughter]
so we said two number one is your cat
likes you and then
in all caps just below that it says and
the reason
you aren't special colin your cat
doesn't like you
oh man the game gave us the one reason
it did i mean that's a good reason
okay cat seems way better wow what does
my cat do when i'm not looking
oh what this like the movie
what your cat does when you're not
looking what is it what is it we need it
what is your cat doing no we oh no
here's why cat should be the next
president of the united states
here's what happens when you try and
take a selfie with your cat uh
i've never seen that symbol before
it's like drawing from like power points
or something
oh what it's just giving give me a
random i'll give you a youtube link
i don't want to click this what you give
me another one wait that's really
interesting uh it's not he's not it's
hold on
i'm not working with you youtube here's
what the here's what your cat does when
you're not looking
one they eat your christmas tree
two they have a go at your christmas
tree three
they try and hide your christmas
presents it's all christmas
and then four they eat your christmas
presents
five cats are [ __ ] eating everything
they try and eat your christmas dinner
six they try and eat the dog's christmas
dinner oh my god
seven they try and eat the dog's kennel
they ate they try and eat the dog in its
kennel
nine they drink your beer
they try and eat your dinner they try
and eat your christmas tree again
you're drinking your dog again again
they do all this stuff everything i just
said they're doing it is doing it again
they don't stop it says again in the
time
and then they rub your face in it
no way
oh my god
okay okay okay um
matt yeah yeah yeah um wow what
what what secrets are george clooney's
worm not telling you
worm pet worm
there's a new hit pet in hollywood
and george clooney shares
what it is his pet worm
oh there you go he's just a little fella
the actor said
of the tiny reptile he keeps
a reptile he's got a couple of worms and
they're
they're having a pretty good time
clinty said he's feeding them twice a
day and they're quote pretty good-sized
i like him a lot because he's so
different he's dead and the only thing
that comes close to being that different
would be a snake
clooney said he had to get a special
license to have the worm
but it was worth it
clooney who is a regular on the people's
choice awards
program hosted the event for the first
time with james corden
i've watched a lot of these so being the
guy at the helm was pretty cool he said
gordon who made a career of making other
people laugh said he was a little
nervous about having a talk show
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah is
the worm coming back just they just lost
the worm
oh my god gordon got in
on the new pet craze too
my dog is my favorite animal i like
animals but i like dogs the most
no we were talking about worms the worm
thing
i have worms he said
gordon said he has i have a worm called
hue i think
i put him in here i'm looking for him i
haven't actually i haven't seen him
but i've got a little pot i've got him
in a little pot horton said he's feeding
him twice a day and a pretty
they're pretty good pretty good
celebrity worms are pretty thick
oh wow here's
what to get your fiance this valentine's
day
a pet worm that worm
tap doesn't mean as long as you get
beyonce a pet worm
oh my god um that's not really working
right now
how about how about um
today mankind stood still as aliens
contacted us for the first time
the leaders of nations gathered when the
alien leader
zorgon descended and gave a speech
oh sorry i can't type i wanna hear i
wanna hear a speech from the first alien
that we meet
basically everyone's always
wondered oh everyone has always
wondered what an alien
would say when he finally
lands on earth and is welcomed
here's a transcript of the aliens
exciting speech
my fellow earthlings you do not know how
long i have been looking for you
it has taken me over two million years
to get here i started my journey
from the planet zoltron which is in the
universe of clark
i've traveled over a million light years
to get here i am a feeling i am a being
you might call an alien
moving looping looping looping looping
looping looping it's not working hard
loop
you know what maybe we should abandon
this angle i just like the motivating
speeches in general
like because they're so funny yeah that
one that we did with
about the war yeah let's just do a
quarter
all the kids in kinder kindergarten
were sad after their
pet worm georgie
got squished got squished
got slipped
into the pencil sharpener oh no it was
ground up oh george their teacher
uh uh
miss jones had the most inspiring
inspire i can't type speech to get
the little kids back on their
back on their feet back on the feet here
we go
to to get the little kids
to cheer up
here we go all right worms worms are
just
like us they have a life cycle that they
must fulfill
nothing in our world is wasted even
worms find a place in this world
some of us will become worm food others
will become fertilizer from
for the trees and plants still others
will become compost for the soil
it's all part of the cycle just like you
worms are born they grow up
and they die it's a fact of life wow the
teachers words were so uplifting that
the kids were completely cheered up
they went back to work as if nothing
happened
and as for georgie the life cycle of
worms is fulfilled when they are ground
up and become compost
[Laughter]
the end this is one of my favorite
children's stories
i hope you share it with your kids to
your success stuart jones
p.s i'm interested in your comments
please share your thoughts
on this story it's a youtuber
copyright stuart jones it's your job
it's a made-up person it goes so much
deeper than you expect like always
it's a complete article yeah it's a
whole article well that didn't quite go
off the rails like i was hoping
no maybe it's kind of inspiring though
um ninety-nine percent of homes are
infected with monkeys
yeah there you go yeah that'll do it
maybe like the top here's how to
find out if your home
is infected
first go to your fridge if there's any
bananas in it throw them away
if there's any apples throw them throw
them away if there's any grapes in the
fruit bowl
throw them away if there's any origins
in the fruit bowl throw them away
now go to the kitchen cupboard if
there's any pots or pans in there
[Music]
throw them away go to the bathroom look
in the toilet if there's any spiders in
there
flush them down the toilet now go to the
bedroom look under the bed
you see any dust bunnies throw them away
if there's any dust bunnies in the
closet too throw those away by the way
if there's an elephant in the closet
throw him away
now that you've thrown away everything
that can be thrown away you have to
disinfect the house
you can use you can use this by either
using a disinfectant
or burning down the house either way
it'll take a long time to do
now when you're done disinfecting the
house all you have to do is move
the next question is where to
go that's easy someplace that doesn't
have monkeys in it
[Applause]
oh my god the comedic timings
realtors have adopted using special
monkey monkey
hyphen detecting goggles
that can spot monkeys
in your home before you even
step through the door
all right oops
oh oh adopted
i'm like sweating from laughing as hard
if you don't want to move
if you don't want to move there's a new
product available
monkey proofing it works like this you
buy some monkey proofing
you apply the monkey proofing you hope
that it works you're done
technically correct yes
okay well i don't think we can go
further on that one i
i i yeah oh god it's a good one give me
give me the best one-liners in history
that i mean what's a good context for
one layers
oh what about pick-up lines best pick-up
lines
pick-up lines that work
in the grocery store in the grocery
store in a specific location
on mars the best pick-up lines that work
in the grocery store
these are not pick-up lines hmm
i wanna get a date at the grocery
store here's
our best pickup
lines when shopping for food
sorry me hey you need a hand her
nope i'm good it's me do you have any
raisins nope but you can have some of my
gum
me i i know right
i know right my sister's such a [ __ ] oh
i'm sorry me no no no it's okay she is
her thanks i guess
me do you sell bootylicious apples here
[Laughter]
uh no me okay i'm gonna get some anyways
uh so this is where the text begins
turning red
oh yeah it's it's that wasn't that bad
that wasn't that bad i just had to read
the bootylicious apples part because
it's like the closest thing to an actual
answer
yeah it's like that that would have been
the one
valid yeah
okay anyways here give me uh uh the year
2030 has been great
for the playstation 7. we want to get
into more video games yeah i want to
hear the top 10 games
after uh after matt cairns
was fired as the director
of panda racer ii
he set out to
make his own independent
video game coming this year for the
for the play station
seven
the game will be set in the same
universe as the first game
but it'll be more of a spiritual
successor than a direct sequel
with the game i wanted to do something
more story driven i wanted to flesh out
the personalities
of the characters more and develop the
world they lived and more so it'd be
easier for the player to relate to it
what i wanted to do was to make
something more akin to older games i
loved growing up like the spyro series
and crash bandicoot
panda 2 panda racer 2 the last resort
is set to release this year and the game
will be available on playstation 7.
the game is going to be produced by the
independent game studio panda games
and it's set to release in the first
quarter of 2019 no
no we're here we go we got our date 20
30. 2030.
these are the games of 2030 lately 2030.
we're gonna have the wrench 2030
has been a big year for
panda pandas
related games
notably
there was nintendo's reveal of the new
console the panda switch
panda switch there's no word if there's
going to be a nintendo switch version or
not oh
matt carranz is also working on a
separate project panda racer
the game it's also a spiritual successor
to panda racer 2.
it will be released in 2031. panda racer
of the game is going to be a mobile game
um this is just all bs yeah
this is like actual articles on the
internet when you're trying to read for
stuff and it's just bs
okay hit me let's get some predictions
going right like
give me like what's going to happen at
the end of 2021 and then give me like
you know bigger pictures from here what
wait and don't stare just be like
it's like 20 20 january or like the new
year is finally here
2021's been a great year here's the top
like historical events that happened in
the year 2021.
top historical
oh let's see well because it goes up to
it cuts off at 2019 so let's see here
[Music]
here's the top historical events that
happened in 2021
one the taliban in afghanistan attacked
the united states
[Music]
this is all just military junk oh it's
just military
the united states approves the
construction of the world's first
successful commercial fusion reactor
the first permanent base on mars is
established wow the president of the
united states is diagnosed with a
terminal illness and it's not expected
to live more than a few months
oh no the united states establishes a
colony on the moon
wow a new religion called the way
develops
and it's quickly spread amongst the
youth of the world
a new system of government is
established in the united states
the first man mission to mars is
successful we got the mars
the oh the united states and canada
merge into a single country called
united states of america
we're not changing our mind we're not
doing it also got a colony on jupiter
colony on saturn
uranus venus mercury neptune pluto
oh neptune's moon saturn's moon
goodness is moved
[Applause]
everything in our solar system okay
instead of writing it as if we're in
2021 let's do a prediction like
uh here's my prediction for what to
expect
in the year 2030 or like how our lives
will be different in the year 2030
how how will our lives drastically
change in the year 2030
some of these facts are going to blow
your mind some of these facts will blow
your
buzzfeed here's how our lives will
dramatically change
in the year 2030
number one will
blow your mind you really should write
for buzzfeed
like i mean once
we're going to be able to control every
part of our bodies with our minds
nice in april duke
university researchers were able to pass
along a quote voluntary electrical
signal
to the brains of
rhesus monkeys using a computer to
control their arms
this is just a now news article
uh two we'll be able to live forever
in 2011 google co-founder larry page
showed off a new company called calico
which was dedicated to the quote
challenge of aging and associated
diseases
uh google has an entire division called
google x
that is dedicated to making life
extending technology the most notable
example
is google glass which uses which allows
the user to live forever
by letting doctors monitor the health of
the user's organs blood and body
[Laughter]
cool three we'll be able to go to space
oh cool
um yeah we sent the dragon uh
uh spacecraft to the international space
station elon musk uh is
building a very cheap and reusable
rocket that will take people to mars and
beyond
musk said he'll die on mars just not on
impact
four we're gonna be able to create our
own food
hello 3d printers can now print out
plastic rubber metal
and now even food in 2014 a company
called natural machines created a 3d
printer you that you can print out pizza
yeah oh five we're gonna be able to
control
our own thoughts so also baseball our
thoughts you're able to control
everything in your body with your mind
six we're gonna look like superhumans
uh
yeah this is basic stuff we already know
cool
yeah um i just need little surprises
like
adidas new shoes
come with a special
surprise in the soul
a tiny munchkin
who directs where your feet
move
[Laughter]
the new adidas x parley shoe has a
special 3d printed sole that has an
arrow pointing in the direction you
should walk
if you look closely you can see the
little munchkin who's right at home in
the shoe's soul
adidas quote the first so this the soul
is the first step to creating
sustainable products that are made with
recycled ocean plastic city adidas
they're made with 100 ocean plastic
ocean plastic uh yeah it's reducing
pollution we have we're gonna be 100
plastic free and all our stuff but
where's this
it kind of kind of glossed over the how
do they get the munchkin where does the
munchkin come from where does this
shoe munchkin come from i'm just gonna
write the munchkin points
the arrow each time
you take a step
okay this is all just corporate pr stuff
about climate change oh wait
oh yes and he doesn't build a new shoe
this week that comes with a tiny
three-dimensional
munchkin who directs where your feet
should go
he keeps talking about ocean plastic
[Laughter]
okay no it can't handle it you can't
handle them
the munchkins are too much oh man the
new fad
that's uh the new fad that's taking
over hollywood all right we need to give
it a wrench
can someone give me a wrench um
constantly
unwrapping while you talk rapping while
you talk
and wearing someone else jordan what do
you got
you're on the spot what are we wearing
scarves around your eyes
eye scarves eye hyphen scarves
where did this new trend come from
question mark
[Music]
all of a sudden all the celebrities are
doing it i don't understand you don't
you have to listen to the lyrics of the
song
they rap when they talk they are the
most amazing things
i'm talking about the rap songs they
make up as they go not the ones that are
written for them but the ones they make
up
as they go
yeah oh it's it's just looping it's
looping getting goofy okay okay all
right
i'm just going to do ice scarves ice
cubes yeah scarves
but uh the governor but the governor
i'm gonna add a little thing of
california
is concerned
he says the scarves are a danger to
public safety to start the new show
you're the worst
tells us why she's wearing them she's a
great comedian but has she lost her mind
that may be the case
she's wearing an ice scarf it's really
nice to meet you thanks for having me
thanks for coming in you're the worst
so this is the new show oh my god uh
we're doing a transcript here this is
just like look i'm very sensitive and
and you wear these ice cubes so is this
this is like a yeah it's a transcript
i'm very sensitive and you wear these
eye scarves i i like it
it's so it's so like a guilty pleasure
there's something about it it's like the
little
valentino of headwear it's not a thing
it's a little bit like when you have a
cold or an allergy you're wearing this
to cover
your eyes but i don't know why you're
wearing it i think it's a little bit of
a fad
i think it's a little bit of a thing why
do you do it
well oh now just it's [ __ ] itself
again
it's it's grown it's going crazy anyways
just more songs songs are great
um okay oh here's this here's one let's
what's like a like a nursery rhyme for
why it's important to wash your eyeballs
out of their outside of the sockets you
take take out your eyes before you wash
them
take out your eyes before you wash them
the nursery most kids don't
take out their eyes before they wash
them thankfully this little nursery
rhyme
um will help them remember
to take them
out oops take them out
all right here we go
uh well let's just describe the book
that does this the fun illustrated book
is perfect for the little ones who are
just learning how to take out their eyes
before they wash them
never mind that's not going anywhere
clean your eyes clean your eyes wash
them very very time
clean your eyes clean your eyes once the
very time wash your eyes wash your eyes
you see you much better clean your eyes
clean your eyes
adapted from hijacked sailor
okay never mind oh man i thought i
wanted that one to work
give me the uh the track list
from the heaviest heavy metal album
ever written this is the satan himself
came out with the heavy metal album
satan just dropped his new
heavy metal album and
we have the inside scoop
on the track list
the track list and the album's
title
we sat down and chatted with satan about
his new album and what he's been up to
lately
i'm just trying to make i'm just trying
to do my thing and make some good music
said satan i'm gonna be releasing my new
album on october 13th
and it's gonna be called heavy metal
thunder
we asked satan what the inspiration was
behind the album
i've been sitting on my throne for a
little while listening to all these
other artists trying to make some heavy
metal
and it just ain't heavy metal it's hard
but it just ain't heavy
and i mean the little guy in the
wheelchair was hard but it wasn't heavy
metal either
so i'm just trying to reclaim the throne
of heavy metal wheelchair guy
we haven't seen that if you had any
collaborators on the album
i've got some of the biggest heavy metal
artists on the album heavy metal legends
heavy metal icons and i'm not going to
tell you who they are i will tell you
that
the fi that five of the songs on the
album have the word devil in them
we asked satan if he could give us a
little preview of what we could expect
from the album
i'll let you hear one of the tracks it's
called if this one's one of my favorites
on the album it's called fire
and brimstone i think it's going to be a
hit listen let's listen to it right now
satan then played the track for us we
were very impressed
if he had any other projects he was
working on i'm also thinking about doing
a clothing line
i was thinking about calling it
devilware
i was going to do this i was going to do
a clothing i was gonna do a clothing
ride
uh a clothing line for these rock and
roll kids i want to do some shirts
jackets pants some underwear
maybe some boxers maybe some briefs i'm
thinking about a whole clothing line
and i've already got the logo designed i
just got to get the ball rolling
i've got big celebrities to endorse it
so that's
what i'm working on
[Laughter]
we asked satan what his favorite heavy
metal album was
hmm what do you think it is my all-time
favorite album
is the number of the beast by iron
maiden
very very apt very active
cool cool makes sense aidan
well all right cool wait what's that
message to the public uh nothing nothing
funny just more garbage
oh my god can we see if we can make it
sing
make it spit out lyrics black
sheep have you any
pizzas
the wheelchair got me the answer is yes
of course
we have it
[Laughter]
so why not make a pizza with baba black
sheep on it
using that as an inspiration i've
created a pizza that goes with the
classic nursery rhyme
and makes a great dish for children
it refuses living anyways it's a recipe
of likes for some italian food
there's no sheep in there we're calling
this italian dish blah blah blah black
sheep
all right uh um tell me about
see if it's too factual like let's say
we're playing mario
and we need some cheat codes or some
cheats how to hack mario
um secrets here's
all the little secrets to find in the
latest
hit game panda eraser
i want to find these little secrets what
are the cheat codes one gear up
to find the secret you're gonna have to
complete the whole game once you do head
over to the shop
in the shop there's a new shop called
secret shop
when you enter it you'll see a secret
item called gold gear
which is an awesome looking gear new
gear
head over to mystery box inside the
mystery box there's an um
there's more gold gear in the mystery
box oh this is garbage
here oh you can unlock hidden characters
like panda king and panda queen
all right uh it's lupin all right did
you know that nintendo's mario was based
on a real man
did you know that nintendo's
famous mario was based
on a real man his name was giovanni and
he lived real new york man
named giovanni
and he lived in new york
in 1750.
not funny not funny
not funny try again bombing he was a
plumbing contractor
yep obviously we know that uh okay
amanda's
in fact giovanni was a very talented man
who was a successful arctic architect
engineer inventor physicist and
mathematician
his surname mario was actually a
nickname given to him by his parents his
real name was actually
giovanni maria giovanni's parents were
both very talented as well father was a
lawyer
able to speak a number of languages such
as spanish french and
english and uh giovanni's father was the
first
person to publish a book in america hmm
wow
his mother was incredibly talented too
she wrote the young gentleman and ladies
philosophy
um i do not see the circling back to
nintendo
[Music]
nope um just give me sam gorski's top 10
sayings oh no oh
no what is sam gorski's top 10 sings sam
gorski
wild man sangrsky's best one-liners
wild man and cool guy has
some of the funniest one-liners
you'll want to say to
[Music]
all your friends
hang up the phone your mother's calling
you your hair looks
great the cannonball run is over i love
you fat pig
oh my god hey you're so ugly that when
you were born your mother said oh lord
what have i done
you don't have a drinking problem you're
just a waste of good booze
man this like version of steve is really
mean
cuts wow okay um
that's not funny it's sad it's a little
sad
is one of the hottest young
skateboarders
[Music]
out there he just invented a nutrition a
new trick
that has everyone talking
he jumped over the empire state building
with no help
here's how
nico grew up in germany and skated at
the skate park at the base
of the empire state building every time
he went down that hill he'd dream about
what it'd be like to jump
over it he drew up the design figured
out how he's gonna clear it calculated
the speed
and worked out worked on that trick for
months finally
he had it he made his way up to the
building to the roof
and took off he jumped the building in
just 1.9 seconds and made the jump
look easy this is the first time
anyone's jumped over the empire
state building and nico didn't even need
a plane to pull it off
share this amazing story with someone
who loves skateboarding
oh man the engagement man what is social
media done to us
it's like a lot of these are that oh
i want to hear about i want to hear
about a snake that learned how to
skydive
oh yeah timmy the snake is the world's
first skydiving snake
um but most didn't
even know a snake could fly
timmy the snake is the world's first
skydiving snake no no no no no no no
repeating okay try it again
i gotta write here's how it went down
let's see how it went down
in recent years timmy has become a
regular feature at the annual aussie
skydive festival
his first flight was on the 9th of june
2014 and he's always
already made it to multiple events
why are people jumping out of planes
with a snake
[Laughter]
[Music]
timmy has become a regular at the aussie
skydive festival for a while now
and he's quickly become a beloved part
of the festival this year he's even part
of the official theme
snakes is the theme
yeah they uh timmy the snake is the
unofficial mascot and an ambassador for
the festival
so we're all asking how does it work the
concept is actually really simple
the skydivers outsource to timmy's
handlers who attach him
to balloons the balloons then float up
to the plane where the skydivers
launch themselves out with timmy the fun
doesn't stop here
the skydivers have to land on a moving
target which is a pretty big challenge
okay why a snake
timmy was named after the festival's
official mascot timmy that
took her on a nog tiger timmy the tiger
is a beloved icon
of this part of canberra and uh they're
embracing the australian outback
the snake on the other hand is a little
more wild i like to think of him as an
ambassador for the outback as well
uh because canavera's uh outback is full
snakes so what's next for timmy
we're hoping to see timmy make more
appearances at skydiving events around
australia in the future
if you're interested if you're
interested at having uh timmy
at your event contact his handlers here
timmy the snake's image is licensed
under creative commons
oh okay oh god great work all right
last last one one more last one oh man
most people gonna be a banger most
people thought dogs couldn't talk
no they can't until now
my golden retriever
surprised me this morning cracking
the code colin how i got my dog
to speak english dude just hit enter
from there
let's see what it writes
i can't type an essay
cracking the code how i got my dog to
speak english this post is part of the
cracking the code series
creating all kinds hi everyone as
promised here's the second post in my
cracking the code series about dog
training
today i want to talk about how to get
your dog to speak english
so a few weeks back i promised that i'd
have a post about how i got my dog to
speak english well here it is
the first thing i did was to figure out
what he was communicating in dog
language
some of you know that i might use dog
speak a language created by turret rugas
to teach my dogs
dog speak uses body language rather than
words to communicate with our dogs
i first got into dog speak when i took a
class with turid in 2002
i took the class to learn how to help a
dog i was working with at the time
gracie who had a lot of behavioral
issues i figured
i needed a little i needed to learn how
to talk to her in a language she
would understand learning how to read
gracie's body language
and speak in a language that she could
understand helped us a lot
she went from being a dog that everyone
saw as aggressive and in need of a
muzzle to being a dog that i let around
the
room on a leash and was able to walk
without a leash on walks around our
neighborhood
so as you see i was a fan of dog speak
right from the start
uh this is about dog speaking
we're gonna insert a line about taking
teaching in english again yeah i forgot
about that
that's when gracie
started speaking english
i was stunned i had never seen anyone
teach a dog to speak
english before i was amazed and a little
concerned i was worried that if gracie
suddenly has a lot of things to say
i'd be stuck listening to her
i started i started working with her on
how to quote
speak on command i had an idea that if i
could teach gracie to speak
and to only say what i told her to say
she'd be able to communicate with me
just like i was talking to her i started
by teaching her to say
yes
and then she'd bark and then no and bark
oh we're in a loop oh no oh god anyway
oh god no this does not want us to teach
dogs let's keep pushing it let's go
now let's do an outro i i i've gotta
bounce here soon um okay
well you can type an outro does anyone
want to sing an outro or do this
and try and give us a little banger yeah
just like here's the script for how to
end the podcast
most people don't know how to end a good
podcast
but here's a few tips on how okay
that's my pitch take it or leave it
sorry i just
it's all about that the buzzfeed
articles speak you just gotta learn that
cadence
and it kind of works really well because
like that's what's trained
that's what was trained on
here's most people don't know how to end
a podcast here's the best
uh the best speech the best the best uh
outro here's a couple good lines to help
you
gracefully finish your recording session
here's a few lines to keep your viewers
coming back for more oh there you go
oh i shouldn't say anything i'm just
saying let's say i'm do it
i just try and sound make it sound super
slick like
okay submit
do you have any questions or insights
for your fellow podcast listeners leave
your comments below or in the show notes
thanks that's it yeah i know it's super
late
one more time you can uh there's a
little also an undo button down there
that's fine it's fine
it's fine you do do it your own way it
works either way
anything that's in the pit please enable
javascript to change the comments
one more time please enable javascript
use that comment it's [ __ ] itself
okay matt your neural nancy needs work
neuromancy
how to end a podcast if you have no
listeners all right
all right okay this is lame there's
nothing there's nothing good here can i
take a crack
yeah all right it's all right it's all
right hold on
uh nope all right i believe in you sam
sam's gonna be ending ending ending up a
long
podcast can be
very difficult what
do you say to your viewers
after all that time here's
a few tips
thank you viewers and listeners for
listening tell them you're looking
forward to the next podcast
ask them to follow you on social media
leave a review on itunes
etc yeah that was saying the same [ __ ]
ask you to subscribe
it knows too well how to end a podcast
ending um
ending a long gnome focused
podcast can be very difficult
thank your viewers gnomecast thank your
viewers they've stuck with you through
thick and thin
and they deserve your appreciation thank
you viewers let them know you won't
disappear entirely
you may be stopping your regular podcast
but you'll continue to post youtube
videos
oh what you can also check out other
gnome stew podcasts
which includes poems like
this it thinks it's a d show
god dang it cooking with gnomes here's
how to say here write me a song
in a hundred languages
adios alvarez ciao aloha
sanara adios
in alien language here's how aliens
say goodbye there you go boom simple
chapter one a few years later
nope it's writing a book
i don't know where that story would be
yeah right all right
nico get the guitar all right
oh you hear me that guitar jordan
oh my god what's inside the guitar oh
this is junks
all right the quarter cast just got a
new outro theme for the podcast
here are the lyrics the corridor written
by ryan allen
[Music]
it's time to go the corridor is calling
us
the call that pulls us the call that
halts us
[Music]
it's looping a single foot step back
goes out across the floors of the great
white house
single footstep it echoes out time to go
yep it's looping around
that's it that's absolutely weird it's
so weird
where are we going whatever
thanks for listening everybody yeah
we'll see you guys on the next one
that's a little fun time
for you in the comments below on the on
youtube or whatever feel free to leave
some ideas
on man i sound just like a freaking ai
oh yeah i do
i mean some ideas from them but
seriously feel free to leave some ideas
for like funny props
yeah yeah i think we got something on
some of your stuff we use some of your
prompts the cooking ones are funny great
cooking ones are hilarious all right
well until next time
bye that was great hola